hey guys so I just wanted to do a quick
video with some thoughts on Kobe Bryant
this is the basketball that I keep on
set over here I've loved basketball my
whole life probably more than anything
besides this whatever this is that I now
do this is crazy and I didn't even tweet
this out but I kid you not on Saturday
afternoon I was flicking the channels
and I saw Kobe on something on Comcast
which is you know they carry the local
Lakers stuff here and you know he does
some broadcasting stuff now and he's
interviewed all the time and I saw him
just for a second as I was flicking the
child and I swear to you I swear I
thought man he is just living his best
life like the guy just looks great he's
so passionate about everything that he
does and it was just like a complete
fleeting moment that I would have never
thought of had what happened on Sunday
not happened so look this is a
extraordinary tragedy not just Kobe
Bryant or his daughter and everybody
else that was on there but there's
something else going on here that I
think is worth talking about and I'd
love to get your feelings on this and I
will actually this will be a rare video
that I actually do read the comments on
when you see somebody who is so clearly
in the prime of their life of their
lives like he wasn't in the prime of his
you know basketball playing life anymore
but was still so at the apex of what
life is and someone who was the ultimate
ultimate ultimate competitor someone
that stood up to every challenge that
there is someone that definitely was a
flawed human being but just kept going
and going and going and then you see
their life cut short and again this is
not to diminish all the other people
that were on there I'm just talking
about the one person that looms large in
many of our worlds somebody that truly
transcended the sport that he played it
just doesn't feel right like it feels
like sort of like a rip in the universe
like how does this happen you know we're
all going on on our daily lives doing
whatever it is that we do I like that
something like this could happen it's
one thing if it happens to somebody and
you know they're not healthy or I don't
know they're just like an awful person
or an error something not that that
makes any more sense in a way but
something like this it feels like it
just like changes like what the fabric
of reality
is out of nowhere and just one other
quick story on this so yesterday
no sorry today's Tuesday on Sunday when
this happened I was jumping in an uber
to go to LAX the airport here and I
noticed that my uber I just found out
just as I was pressing the uber I opened
my phone and I saw the notification and
I was immediately like kind of my eyes
kind of teared up and I yelled out to
David that Kobe Bryant died and kind of
couldn't believe it not his praying he
was a hoax and the whole thing anyway I
pressed my uber and I noticed for about
five minutes my uber doesn't move and I
was about to cancel it and then he
started moving my uber comes to the
house and I get in the car and it's a
young guy probably in his late twenties
happens to be a black guy and he was
hysterical crying hysterical
hysterically crying and I kind of teared
up and I said and he was he said
something like he wasn't sure if he
could drive maybe he shouldn't pick me
up and I was like I was in a bit of a
rush but I was like listen don't worry
we can just relax for a little bit kind
of sat there for a couple minutes and
then and then he drove me to LAX it's
about a 45 minute drive and we just
talked about basketball the entire time
we talked about Kobe the 81-point game
all the championships the Matt Barnes
moment where Kobe doesn't flinch all of
that stuff and it's just so weird how
these people that you don't know
personally in any way can affect you in
huge ways anyway yesterday I just had a
hard time thinking about anything else
besides that and then I got to LAX and
there were so many adults adults crying
everyone glued to every TV and and it's
just weird and I'm curious just sort of
what you guys think about you know when
you when you lose heroes or somebody
young dies unexpectedly how does that
affect you you know the guy lived with
the ultimate passion for what he loved
to do and I tweeted something like this
but it's like if all of us could do that
a little bit better just think of the
unimaginable ways we could change the
world so here's to you Kobe I mean he's
definitely he's playing ball with some
of the greats right now I feel like he's
talking with with Naismith as we speak
so yeah let me know your comments right
down below